à la base la recette est classique
frites fromage en grains et de la sauce
brune
ce qui est étonnant c'est que ce
restaurant spécialisé dans la poutine a
pignon sur rue dans l'un des quartiers
les plus branchés de paris et fils ne
désemplit pas moi je viens découvrir mes
nouveaux mails socialité donc ouverte à
la fin du mois de novembre la maison
jacques outin a même été victime de son
succès forcé de fermer en raison de
ruptures de stock
on appelle ces secrets de réussite selon
chef une bonne promotion sur les médias
sociaux du bouche à oreille et surtout
des mois de travail à peaufiner le
produit avant tout dans ma façon
d'aborder la chose c'était de respecter
la poutine avant tout pas de pas aller
trop loin pour l'adapter parce que ce
qui m'intéressait c'était d'amener un
plat nouveau quelque chose d'eux
de différents qu'on n'a pas en france le
chef erwan caradec et français mais s'il
a travaillé pendant cinq ans dans les
restaurants de montréal j'ai parler son
coeur on t'aime a rarement chez sa fille
on a ramené un amour pour l'art aux
québécoises avaient la cote est ce là
[Applaudissements]
une obsession ferrer meyjes poutine aux
français qui a commencé par le fromage
qu'il est tenu par couvrir savoir
fabriquer selon la même recette fait
qu'elle est effectif
ici l'idée de base est la même
erwan avoue avoir adapté la poutine au
goût français
la différence majeure c'est plus dans la
texture de la sauce massot cet impôt -
stif à la croche un petit peu moins sur
le sur le fromage
il propose ainsi plusieurs variations
sur le thème en y ajoutant des lardons
des oignons de couler et bientôt du foie
gras avec des noms de circonstance et si
la plupart des clients sont confrontés
pour la première fois au concept même de
poutine les premières impressions sont
plutôt bonnes
c'est trop beau
c'était très très bon mais j'ai donné
tout ce que j'avais pour finir et les
raisons loi alors évidemment le
rapporteur ne serait pas complet sans un
test gustatif et pour bien évaluer une
poutine il faut bien évidemment un peu
les québécois verdict pas mal du tout
ici jean françois bélanger laso canada